Cyber security is one of the fastest
growing and most respected fields today
and earning your CIS certification can
open the door to some of the highest
paying and most trusted roles in the
industry. But passing the CIS isn't just
about memorizing facts. It's about
understanding how to think like a
security leader. That's exactly what
this course is designed to do. I will
walk you through every domain, simplify
complex topics and share real world
example that will help you not only pass
the exam but truly master cyber
security. So before we begin, like this
video, hit that subscribe button and
turn on the notification bell.
Welcome to the domain number six,
security assessment and testing. And
this domain carries a weightage of 12%.
So let's get started. And our first
topic is about security assessment
itself. That what is a security
assessment? Security assessment is
evaluation of an object such as
evaluation of risks or the processes
inside organization. It measures how
well the security controls, policies or
systems perform.
An example of assessment is the risk
assessment which identifies assets and
evaluates likelihood and impact of
risks.
So an uh a related term to the
assessment is audit. So what is an
audit? So audit is a formal systematic
evaluation against a defined standard.
Audit determine if a system or process
meets specific criteria. For example,
PCI DSS that is payment card industry
and data security standard. So an
organization that processes the credit
card information of customers can be
evaluated. The organization processes
its security controls can be evaluated
against this standard.
Audit is more structured and compliance
focused than assessment. So this is the
uh difference between audit and
assessment. So the purpose of assessment
is to evaluate effectiveness while the
purpose of audit is to verify
compliance.
The assessment is internal or informal
while the audit is based on external or
formal standard. The focus of assessment
is to identify risks and improvement
while the focus of audit is to to check
adherence to policies and standards.
So the output of both the assessments
and audits are reports that details
actions, findings and gaps.
Deficiencies are controls that are not
working as intended and gaps are missing
or insufficient controls
and both should be treated as risk. Both
these deficiency and gaps they should be
treated as risk and prioritized for
remediation and medication.
So what is the role of testing? So
testing gathers information to support
assessment or audits. We conduct testing
during audits or during assessments.
Testing can be either automated or
manual and it is used for ongoing verifi
ongoing verification of control
effectiveness
and it provides timely data for
correcting issues and improving security
posture.
So the purpose of audit assessment and
test strategies. So all three activities
that is audit, assessment and test they
incur costs and therefore proper
planning ensures efficiency.
So the strategies are designed to
monitor and improve the security
posture, scope and targets of these
audits, assessment and test strategies
should align with system or process
value to the organization.
regulatory or contractual requirements
and using standard methodologies ensures
repeatability and measurable return on
investment or ROI.
So we have two types of assessment and
audits. One is the internal assessment
and audits. So these are conducted
within the organization using the
internal staff. They are conducted by
the internal staff of the organization
itself and these are useful for
continuous monitoring and readiness
checks before external audits.
The advantages of internal assessment
and audits include that they are lower
cost.
Of course the internal staff of the
organization has the internal knowledge
of all the processes and assets and
therefore remediation can be done
faster. Disadvantages of the internal
assessment and audits are that conflict
of interest are possible. For example,
the internal staff
auditing their own systems results in
conflict of interest. So it is less
subjective than external audits.
The mitigation is that internal audit
team should report independently of
departments being audited.
So some examples of internal auditing.
First one is the vulnerability scanning
which is routine unpatched
system checks.
process audits for example the change
management and training completion and
fishing simulations to test user
awareness.
Second type of assessment and audits are
the external types which are conducted
by independent third parties with no
conflict of interest. External audits
and assessment provides impartial,
specialized and credible evaluations and
they are commonly used for penetration
testing also called as pen testing and
compliance test for example compliance
test of PCIDSS
ISO 27,01 and fed RAM external
assessment and audits are required for
organizations that handle regulated
regulated data data are high assurance
environments.
What are some benefits of external
audits? Benefits include that they
provide fresh perspective and identify
unseen issues.
They enhance the credibility and
compliance assurance and they are cost
effective for specialized skills for
example pen testing. We also saw that
internal audit benefit was that they are
of low cost and here we are saying that
uh external audits are cost effective
for specialized skill like pens testing.
It is because uh once when you do pen
testing you can just hire a team to do
the pen testing and it is cost effective
rather than keeping the pent testers for
the whole time inside your organization.
So doing a one-time activity or hiring
for a specialized skill for a one-time
activity is cost effective than owning
your own team and tools to do this
specialized task.
Our next topic is third party and supply
chain audits. So they focus on the
vendors, suppliers and service providers
critical to the operations of the
organization. These identify the risk
and dependencies in the supply chain and
they should include vendors handling
sensitive or regulated data and provides
for essential or outsource services.
So use third-party reports such as sock
two type two reports that verify
suppliers security controls.
So CISP must ensure that supplier
services were within the audit scope.
So what is the purpose of security
controls testing? So they ensure that
controls are implemented and operating
as intended. So this is the purpose of
security control testing.
This test basically detects deficiencies
or controls that are no longer
effective.
and provides data for corrective action
and continuous improvement.
They can be performed internally or
externally. An example of security
control testing is testing media
disposal controls via procedure reviews,
staff interviews, and physical
verification.
Our next topic is the vulnerability
assessment. The vulnerability assessment
identifies weaknesses that could be
exploited.
It supports continuous monitoring and
proactive defense,
detecting vulnerabilities in hardware,
operating system, applications and
network.
Assessing impact and prioritizing
remediation
outputs of vulnerability assessment
helps identify insecure configuration or
protocols for example FTP or file
transfer protocol
and compensating protocols like next
like network segmentation can reduce the
risk
vulnerability assessment asset inventory
what's the role of asset Inventory
inability assessment. So it is the
foundation of an effective vulnerability
assessment.
Asset inventory helps identify the
critical systems and their importance.
Appropriate tools and the scan
frequency.
Data may come from a business impact
analysis. The business impact analysis
is also used to identify critical system
and their prioritization.
Scans can be prioritized by the system
criticality. For example, PCI systems
may have more frequent scans such as
weekly scans because of their
criticality and internal or nonsensitive
scan systems may have less frequent
scans such as monthly or quarterly.
Vulnerability scanning tools inside
vulnerability assessment. So they
identify vulnerabilities in host
networks and applications
and the tools can be both open-source
and commercial.
So the typical steps in uh in the
vulnerability assessment scanning tools
include to discover the assets via the
IP address or the IP address range to
scan for uh scan for active services for
example FTP or HTTP to check versions
patches and configurations and to
compare findings against known
vulnerabilities
that are present in CVE and EVSS
databases.
What are some key considerations during
vulnerability assessments? So these
include the compliance obligations maybe
legal or regulatory requirements depth
and coverage of vulnerability
assessments. So we may carry out the
credential scans that reduce false
positive
platform support ensure compatibility
with all systems cloud limitations. So
SAS provider software as a service
provider may restrict scanning of their
application
and review providers own scan reports
for supply chain insurance. So the
vendors or providers have their own scan
reports. They should be reviewed and
checked for supply chain.
So what is the difference between
credential and non-credential scan? So
credential scan gives external view and
have no admin access to the system. Pro
is that it is fast and low risk and cons
is that it has the limited visibility of
the system and uh server host etc.
Credential scan on the other hand uses
administrative credentials to login. The
results are accurate and it is uh it
require more effort to set up the
credential scan.
So what are some common vulnerability
assessment issues? So these include
number f number number one is excessive
traffic and denial of service. So
vulnerability scanners can overload
system or network by sending large
amounts of traffic. So this may cause
denial of service conditions or slow
performance. Prevention of this may be
to enable request throttling to limit
the scan request to use credential scan
to gather information directly from
system instead of sending the network
probes and to schedule scans during
offbears or spread them over time.
Second issue is the alerts and
incidents. So scanners mimic attacker
behavior. For example, port scans are
carried out by the attacker as well as
during the vulnerability assessment
which can trigger security alerts or
incident response processes. So how to
prevent this issue? So we may need to
configure security tools to ignore the
scanner IP addresses. So we know from
which IP addresses the scanning or
vulnerability assessment
uh is being carried out. So we know to
ignore the alerts from those IP
addresses and to notify the security
operations team such as the sock team or
the steam team
that is security information and event
management before scanning to avoid
confusion so that they know that
vulnerability assessment is being
carried out inside the organization.
Third issue is the crossf functional
ownership. So security team runs the
scan but the other departments owns the
system against which the scans are run
and these systems are are have the
vulnerabilities. So without the
cooperation from these departments
findings may be ignored. Therefore, the
best practices include to communicate
findings in businessfriendly language,
not just CVSS scores and to foster
collaboration and accountability between
IT, DevOps and security teams.
Third issue is the data integr integrity
pollution. So the scanners test web
inputs such as SQL injection or
cross-sight scripting and may enter fake
data into live system. So this can
pollute real data or trigger unintended
actions like sending emails. The
prevention of this issue is to exclude
sensitive fields from scans to use test
or staging environments instead of
production and to tag or easily identify
test data for cleanup.
Fifth issue is the network segmentation.
So firewalls, vans or zero trust
architectures may block scanners from
reaching all the systems. And the
solution is to deploy distributed
scanning agents with each segment and to
aggregate results centrally for
analysis.
So next topic is the penetration testing
or pen testing. So penetration testing
goes beyond vulnerability assessment.
So vulnerability assessment only check
for the vulnerabilities and the
pentesting actually try to exploit those
vulnerabilities. So the goal is to
exploit vulnerabilities to determine the
real world impact. It is conducted by
ethical hackers who simulate the
attacker behavior. The output of
penetration testing is a report that
helps the organization fix
vulnerabilities like fix the
vulnerabilities unlike real attackers
that cause harm.
So what are the benefits and drawbacks
of the pen testing? So benefits include
that the pent testing confirms if one
abilities can be truly exploited
and it validates security controls and
the real risk level. Robic is that it is
costly and requires skilled
professionals
and the risk of disruption. So the
pentesting may cause system downtime or
instability.
So what are pentesting approaches? So we
may have the white box testing also
known as crystal box testing. In this
type of testing the pen testers has full
knowledge of systems for example their P
addresses their operating system
versions etc.
And it basically simulates the insider
threat because the insider also has all
the information of the systems.
And this type of testing provides
complete test coverage.
Next is the opposite of white box
testing which is blackbox testing where
pentesters has no prior knowledge and
tester only perform reconnaissance to
gather the information.
It stimulates an external attacker
scenario and this type of testing may
miss hidden or undiscovered
assets. So if the their reconnaissance
miss some asserts or IP addresses so we
can say that the coverage may be not
complete in widebox testing all the
systems are covered because all the
systems are not. In blackbox testing,
some system may be missed due to uh
reconnaissance issue or due to the
system were not properly detected and so
the coverage will not be complete.
In between these two is the gray box
testing which combines the white and
black box testing approaches.
So in this type of testing the testers
have partial system knowledge and it
balances the realism and depth of
testing.
So the gray box testing reflects how a
typical attacker might exploit limited
internal information.
The key takeaways are that pentesting is
active exploitation for validation and
not just detection of the
vulnerabilities. Ethical hacking
basically provides actionable insights
for improving defenses.
So use different testing models
depending on security objectives and
real attackers have more time. So
testing should be periodic and
strategic.
So what are some pentesting rules? So
pent testing is a high risk activity and
can cause incidents, downtimes or legal
issues. Therefore, it should always be
performed under contract with
indemnification clauses to protect
testers.
A rules of behavior document defines
what testers can and cannot do. Proper
management and coordination are critical
responsibilities of a system.
What are the rules of behavior? The
rules of behavior basically provides
clear guidance for testing activities.
They help prevent legal, operational or
ethical violations and ensure the
organization is prepared for test
related alerts or incidents and
coordinates communication between
testers and internal teams.
So what are the pen testing phases? So
the first one is the discovery also
known as reconnaissance and the goal of
this phase is to gather the target
information and key activity or tools
you said in used in this phase are the
OS that is open source intelligence DNS
lookup may be carried out social media
may be checked for gathering the
information
is an online uh search security related
search engine such as Google where we
can search for uh uh you can say CCTV
cameras
uh other networks switches firewalls
that are available on internet and check
their security and observation. Phase
two is scanning and probing. This phase
the goal of this phase is to identify
vulnerabilities and entry point into the
systems. Some tools and activities
inside this phase is N map. N MAP is a
network scanning tool, Pink Sweeps,
Banner grabbing and vulnerability
scanner. So these are tools are used for
scanning and probing.
And third phase is the exploitation
which tries to gain during this phase
the attacker or ethic ethical hackers
try to gain the unauthorized access
and the tools used during this phase
include the metaslo password crackers
such as John the reaper or hashcat and
burp suit. Phase number four is the post
exploitation. During this phase, the
goal is to expand access and gather
data. And key activities during this
phase include privating, privilege
escalation and internal footprinting.
And the last phase is the reporting. And
reporting goal is to document the
findings and recommend fixes.
And the key activities or tool during
this phase include detailed report,
executive summary and remediation plan.
So the detailed reports are basically
for the internal team or the
administrators of the system while the
executive summary are for the senior
management such as CEO, CFO or CISO etc.
So what is the physical pen testing? So
the purpose of physical pan testing is
to elevate the effectiveness of physical
security controls protecting systems,
data and facilities. And the goal is to
identify weaknesses such as poor access
control, untrained staff or insecure
entry points. Method of physical pen
testing include tailgating or piggy
banking. social engineering such as
posing as staff posing as vendor or
delivery staff wage cloning or
unauthorized entry dumpster diving for
sensitive information. So the CIS focus
is that test to test the CIS basically
test physical control layer in defense
in depth and supports risk assessment by
validating real world exploitability.
Our next topic is the log review. So the
purpose of the log review is that logs
act as a detective controls to identify
unauthorized or abnormal activities
and sources of logs include systems,
endpoints, network devices and
applications.
And CIS focus is to ensure logs are
enabled, properly configured and
regularly reviewed.
and they supports incident detection and
audit verification of security controls.
For example, if access is restricted to
business hours, logs must show whether
log must show both successful and denied
access attempts for proof of control
enforcement.
Audit and compliance expect. So log
management must include policies and
procedures for generation, storage,
protection and review of logs. Define
roles and responsibilities for log
monitoring, retention and integrity
mechanisms for example riot once storage
hashing.
So audit relevance include logs provide
evidence of compliance with frameworks
like ISO 27,01
PCIDSS
and NIST SP800-53.
The key point is that logging without
review offers no security value. So
regular analysis is mandatory. What does
this mean? This mean that if the logs
are stored, if the system do produce
logs but they are never reviewed then
they are of no use. So log should be
regular regularly reviewed for
compliance.
So what is synthetic transactions
overview? So these are automated test
actions performed on monitor systems or
applications to verify availability,
functionality and performance and the
purpose is that it stimulates simulates
real user behavior to confirm that
system respond as expected. For example,
logging into a web application using a
test account and sending a DNS query or
DHCP request to verify service
responsiveness.
What are some use cases and comparison
of synthetic transactions?
So key uses include SLA or service level
agreement monitoring. So it confirms
uptime commitment for example 99.9%
service availability.
If the SLA has promised 99.9%
availability we can confirm this
commitment through synthetic transaction
data integrity monitoring. So it
verifies that business logic processes
data correctly. We can confirm this true
synthetic transaction
system and service monitoring. So it is
used to detect offline on or
unresponsive system such as heartbeat
test.
So a related concept is the real user
monitoring or RUM
which tracks actual user interaction in
real time. The risk is that it may
capture sensitive data cause privacy or
compliance issues.
So CIS inside synthetic transactions are
controlled, predictable and privacy safe
ways to verify system health and SLA
compliance.
Our next topic is the code review and
testing. So the purpose of code review
and testing is to identify and fix
software flaws before deploying the
software
so that to prevent vulnerabilities that
can compromise data and system. So
testing approaches again include
blackbox testing where we have no access
to the source code and it simulates an
external attacker behavior.
Widebox testing provides full access to
source code and internal logic. Testing
methods include manual review which is
PR code reviews to find logic or syntax
errors and automated testing which is
static analysis
that is through uh which scans source
code for loss and dynamic analysis which
observe running program behavior.
So what are frameworks and their
integration in code review and testing?
So key key frameworks include CWE which
is a catalog of common software
weaknesses, CVSS
which rates severity of vulnerabilities
and OASP top 10 which list most critical
web application risk. So integration in
development include testing early in
software development like circle and dev
secc ops that is CI/CD pipelines.
Use store for automated security
response and balance security coverage
and development speed to meet business
goals.
Our next topic is the misuse and abuse
case testing. So the purpose of misuse
and abuse case testing is to test how
system respond to unexpected or invalid
inputs and to identify vulnerabilities
that are exploitable under abnormal
conditions. Example include leaving the
password blank at login. For example, it
is covered in CVE-20 201713872
vulnerability
and entering text where numbers are
expected or null values. Abuse cases
include
describe intentional or malicious misuse
by attackers
and this help define security
requirements and support threat
modeling.
So the misuse and abuse case testing
definition is that it measures how much
of a systems code or functions are
testing tested. It ensures critical
areas for example authentication admin
functions are covered. So the coverage
types include branch coverage where
every branch and decision logic is
executed. Condition coverage where all
boolean conditions are tested true or
false. Function coverage uh where every
function is executed and statement
coverage where all lines of code run. So
the goal is aim for maximum feasible
coverage. Use compensating controls if
full coverage is impractical.
Our next topic is the interface testing.
So the purpose of interface testing is
to validate functionality and security
of interaction points for example user
interface API or CLI. Focus areas
include input validation to reject
malformed data, access control and
logging for confidentiality and
nonrepudiation
and testing both normal and abnormal
inputs. The special considerations
include web interfaces
for session management, cookies and
external user access and critical
interfaces of app server, web server and
databases
to
check for defense in web.
Our next topic is bridge and attack
stimulation B.
So it is automated continuous testing
simulating realworld attacks. It
combines vulnerability scanning and
automated pan test penetration testing
and it helps identify weaknesses more
frequently than periodic testing.
The purpose of breach and attack
simulation is to evaluate security
control effectiveness against new and
evolving threats and to detect gaps or
misconfiguration in defenses.
Attack categories include endpoints
which simulates malware to test endpoint
detection and response detection.
network which sends malicious traffic to
test firewalls and routers.
Email that test spam filters and
spoofing protection
and behavior base which evaluates
responses to suspicious activities or
scams.
The compliance checks and audits. So the
purpose of compliance is to define
industry or region specific risk to
implement controls to mitigate the risk
and start
starting point for risk management not
the ultimate security goal.
Compliance checks include to verify
controls, verify controls meet the
required objectives, identify
deficiencies or ineffective control and
to detect controls that are not properly
executed due to change risk. Audit and
assessment evaluate security at a
specific point in time. Example include
ISO 27,01
every 3 years carried out by external
auditor and annual internal audit.
PCIDSS is annual third party audit and
quarterly vulnerability scans.
Ped ramp is is ongoing annual assessment
plus continuous monitoring
performance period audits. So SOCK 2
type 2 N ISO 27,01 review controls over
a period for example the past year.
Continuous monitoring detects early
weaknesses before attackers explain them
exploit them. So balancing compliance is
to consider cost and operational
overhead and align with threat landscape
and risk of non-compliance.
Goal is to identify weaknesses early,
take corrective action and maintain
security posture.
Collecting security process data. So the
purpose is to monitor effectiveness of
security controls in mitigating risk.
This role is to ensure data is
collecting collected and analyzed to
support oversight.
Continuous monitoring steps include to
perform risk assessment and implement
control to enable logging on all system
central log and automate the monitoring
for example through seam platform
metrics or raw data to use key
performance indicators or KPIs to
identify trends and apply artificial
intelligence and machine learning for
automated data analysis.
Security metrics programs focus on
relevant data. So it monitors trends for
example change request requiring roll
back. Identify deficient processes and
improve procedure.
Designing metrics program understand
security program objectives
reference for metrics. Ensure controls
are measurable. For example, MFA
required for all login. Query access
logs to verify 100%
en enforcement
technical controls and metrics. So
implement with these are implemented
with electronic system for example
username and password and firewall data
collection. So system usually support
native logging for example application
access log router firewall logs. The
technical matrix program measure
multi-layered security using three
strategies. Number first one is prevent
which is done through encryption, secure
key management, VPN and hostbased
firewall. Second is detect which is done
through EDR seam monitoring hardware and
software for anomalies. And third is
respond which is again done through EDR
network and hostbased intrusion
prevention system to correct incidents
administrative controls and metrics. So
these are the policies and procedures
for example acceptable use policies
access reviews and personal controls.
Data collection include direct through
documentation and digital records and
indirect through artifacts like guard
walk through logs or incident reports.
An example of policy may be the social
media policy. So the policy reach should
be to number of user who acknowledge the
policy. Education effectiveness can be
measured by users attempting restricted
access and technology effectiveness can
be measured by number of users able to
bypass web filters effectiveness of
technical control.
Account management. So accounts are
credential used to access resources for
example username and password and
encryption keys. Importance of account
management is the access control is
fundamental to information system
security and blended control types
include administrative which include
policies procedure access request
approval processes. Technical control
include identity and access management
tool, active directory or octa, network
access control, API key management and
physical control type include access
restricted bases, tokens, smart cards
and trusted devices.
The timely account management is to
remove access promptly after role change
or termination.
Notifications are to receive alerts for
provisioning and deprovisioning within
defined time frame. Account review is to
ensure periodic review per organization
schedule and process execution is that
proper password distribution and resets.
Verification steps followed before
access changes and network access
controls properly configured.
Management review and oversight.
So role of management is to define and
execute organizational mission including
security and privacy
and to provide supports sponsorship and
direction for security initiatives.
So the purpose of review is to ensure
controls function as intended and reduce
risk to acceptable levels
and to detect changes in operating
environment that may render controls
ineffective. For example, new system
regulatory changes and mergers. Data for
decision makings can come from
assessments, audits and security process
metrics inform both short-term for
example BCP activation and long-term
decisions for example migration to the
cloud. So the stakeholders includes
senior and executive management system
and data owners and custodians.
So management reviews for compliance. So
framework requires include ISO 27,019.3.
So periodic review of program
suitability, adequacy and effectiveness
and fed ramp assess authorize and
monitor systems. Use metrics to maintain
ATO certification and accreditation.
Evaluate and formally approve system for
fit fitness and compliance.
Track two establish performance measure
and use quality information to support
internal controls. COIT is a high level
management oversight, planning, capacity
and control program reviews. The key
point include continuous monitoring
metrics, feed management review and it
ensures ongoing risk mitigation and
control effectiveness.
key performance indicators or KPIs.
So the purpose of KPIs is to measure
effectiveness of existing security
controls.
What's the difference between KPI and
metrics? So metrics are raw measurements
for example
number of paged applied inside an
organization
while KPIs are constructualized
metrics for example percentage of end
points paged within 7 days.
What are some design considerations for
the KPIs? So they should align with
organizational goals and risk mitigation
objectives.
They should establish baselines and
thresholds for performance. And
we can use frameworks like ISO 27,04,
NIST SP800-55
or GKIM method.
So some example of KPIs include MTD that
is meanantime to detect detect which is
the average time to identify an
incident. Meantime to resolve which is
MTR that is average time to resolve
incidents. Security scores which
measures the maturity of security
efforts and return on investment of
security controls which is used to
balance cost versus risk reduction
inside organization.
Next is the key risk indicators or KRIS.
So the purpose of KIS is to monitor
potential future risks and changing
threat landscape.
Proactive mitigation. So indicators
drive proactive actions. For example,
firewall upgrades, patching. Sources of
KISS are vulnerability scans, audits,
incident response data, and malware
reports. And examples of KIS include
number of security incidents. So rising
numbers may indicate new threats. Number
of audit finding which highlights
deficiencies in security program
fishing attempts detected or reported
which gives early warning for credential
attacks. Unpatched endpoints. So the
threshold breach signals vulnerability
exposure. So benefits of kis are that
they support long-term management
decisions and resource planning.
Backup verification
data. So the purpose of backup
verification data is to ensure backups
are usable to maintain data integrity
and availability. And key steps include
number one to identify critical data and
systems necessary for operations. Number
two, to design a backup strategy aligned
with recovery needs. Number three is to
verify backup integrity by performing
test restores.
And some indicators of issues are
missing or unreadable data which leads
to possible configuration errors or
media corruption.
Automation and monitoring. So some
backup systems support automatic
integrity checks.
So alerts for integrity loss are
automatic retry of failed backups.
Training and awareness metrics. So the
users are both a lines users inside an
organization or humans. We can say both
are uh they are both a line of defense
as well as a high value target for
attacks. The security awareness,
education and training programs must be
monitored for effectiveness. So key
metrics to monitor the effectiveness of
training and awareness include training
completion rates to identify users at
risk due to incomplete training,
information retention and habit
building. Ensure knowledge is retained
over time. Coverage which means update
training to address evolving threats and
risk. And number four, audience needs.
So tailor content to technical level and
relevance for users.
Next is the disaster recovery and
business continuity that is BCDR.
So the purpose is to maintain
availability via effective BCDR plan and
key question or metrics for BCDR include
to plan documentation and updates
personal awareness and training plan
accessibility and critical functions
capture organizational changes reflected
testing and addressing deficiencies.
Third party depend dependencies tested
and integration with change management.
Our next topic is analyze the test
output and generate report. So the
purpose is to summarize findings from
security evaluations such as
vulnerability scans, penetration test,
audits and continuous monitoring
and provide actionable insights for
decision making. Audience considerations
include some audience may be executive
which are the higher level strategy
which gives
higher level strategic uh insights and
risk management actions while technical
teams require detailed fighting raw
output and remediation guidance. So
report structure is executive summary
for highlevel uh management plus
technical appendex for the technical
teams dashboard or drill down views for
multiple audiences.
So the report life cycle. So first one
is the draft report which is preliminary
preliminary filing for quick
communication and then we have the final
report to adjust severity remove false
positive and include compensating
control.
So we may have automated or manual
reporting. So automated report is
generated via CVSS based scores and
dashboards while manual is needed for
environmental and temporal context to
accurately reflect risk. Goal is to
communicate findings effectively and
support timely informed remediation and
strategic decision making.
So typical audit report contents include
so the audit report content provides a
structured summary of security
evaluations for informed decision
making. The key sections of the audit
report include first one is the
executive summary which is highlevel
overview of finding and it is usually of
one page.
Test boards can summarize findings with
drill down option.
Section number two is assumption and
constraint which clarifies testing
limitation for example time and scope of
test and provides context for findings.
Number three is the scope which defines
coverage such as the system, network or
facilities that are tested and it
ensures that readers understand what is
included and what are excluded from the
tests.
Number four is summary of activities
which lists test evaluations or audit
actions performed, demonstrates work
completed by the assessment team. Number
five is the findings and issues which
includes deficiencies or vulnerabilities
with severity, location and supporting
evidence. Number six is recommendation
which may be generic. For example, apply
all pages or detailed such as specific
system commands or configuration. Seven
is appendices which include raw data or
technical details and provides reference
for technical audiences while keeping
main report concise.
So the goal is to present actionable
insights and balance readability for
executive with technical depth for
prementors.
remediation and exceptional exception
handling. So remediation address
findings from audits, assessments or
tests
and it requires project managements to
prioritize set timelines and milestone
and track progress.
Plans may be called POM risk mitigation
or audit issue mitigation plans. So key
plan elements include finding details
and mitigating circumstances,
prioritization and time frame and
resources required and milestone. So pen
testing may be performed to verify fixes
especially for software vulnerabilities.
So what is the ethical disclosure of
vulnerabilities? So the purpose is to
ensure vulnerabilities are reported
responsibly before exploitation.
So disclosure policy should include
reporting procedure and expected
response timeline recognition or payment
for reported vulnerabilities
and the scope is that in scope versus
out of scope vulnerabilities. The rules
for ethical disclosure include that the
ethical hacker should report
vulnerabilities to responsible
organization only to conduct work in
good faith and within the law to allow
organization time to remediate before
public disclosure
and optional is financial in uh
incentives via bug bounty programs.
So some special circumstances include
non-disclosure due to legal contractual
obligations, full disclosure versus
responsible disclosure, mandatory
reporting to authorities if required and
whistleblowing protections for ethical
reporting,
designing and conducting the security
audits. So the purpose is to compare an
organization's processes and control
against a defined standards. So that's
what's the purpose of conducting a
security audit
through designing a security designing
an audit program uh include
so the audit can include or the audit
can be internal, external or both types
of audit. They both can be designed for
an organization.
So conducting or designing audit
basically requires management support,
resources and a recurring schedule and
recurring audits take progress and
demonstrate improvement over time.
So some common audit frameworks include
SS AE18 which is used for SOCK 2 audits.
So remember the SOCK 2 audits they are
important from exam point of view. ISO
15408 and 18045 which is the common
criteria for IT security evaluation. ISO
27,0006 which is requirements for ISO
27,01 certification audits.
NIST SP800-53A
which guides assessment of security and
privacy controls. NIST cyber security
framework and ped SAF which is freely
available framework for consistent
evaluations.
So sampling is used to balance audit
effort and assurance. For example to
select representative samples. For
example, if there are thousand servers,
we can select 100 sample from that
thousand server because one cannot audit
all the servers inside the organization.
If the servers uh are of let's suppose
we have uh 500 servers of Linux,
having uh let's suppose Windows
operating system. So a good balance
sample would be to take 50 from Linux
and 50 from Windows. So this would
constitute a good sample to conduct the
audit.
Internal audits are conducted by staff
familiar with system by internal staff.
Advantages include as we already studied
they are cost effective and the uh the
staff has better knowledge of the
environment. Disadvantages are that
possible bias of the staff due to their
own system or lack of independence. It
is useful for readiness before the major
external or compliance audits.
External audits are conducted by
independent professional for example CBA
or Sock 2. Advantages include they are
unbiased
uh conducted by experts and required for
compliance for example PCI ISO 27,01
disadvantages include that they uh incur
higher cost and the conductors are the
auditors have less familiar uh
familiarity with the internal operations
and systems of the organization.
So then we have third party audits which
evaluate the vendors, partners or cloud
providers that deals with that specific
organization
and they identify risk that could impact
your organization due to these third
parties. Common reports of third party
include sock 2, CSA star. Key questions
are that what standards and controls are
used, what findings exist and how they
are uh remediated and are any risk
hidden due to limited information.
So that's all for this domain. I hope
this domain has been uh informative for
you. So please like, share the video and
subscribe for the seventh domain. See
you in the next video.